Welcome to ICT for dummies episode 5. Well, we just did for fucking you
We just read you are so fucking retarded. Just you're so retarded. You're so retarded episode 5 guys
To fair value guys
This is where price attracts
Yeah
For value guys
Reacts
Green or red homie
Black away like charts that are also like black and white and we don't discriminate
So over this video we're gonna be going over for value gaps
What exactly is a fair value gap though? So for value gap is basically just an imbalance in price
So when price has huge movements in the market, we leave behind
Imbalances imbalances are from an inefficiency of orders getting filled
so what price tends to do is trade back into these inefficiencies and use them as areas of support or areas of
Resistance, so there's two different types of fair value gaps. We first have here a sell side imbalance
This is a bearish fair value gap also known as a SIBI a sell side imbalance
And what a fair value gap essentially is is when the low of the first candles wick
Doesn't overlap with the high of the third candles wick or in a bullish sense the high of the first candles wick
It doesn't overlap with the low of the third candles wick here
We have it broken down into really five main components that make up a fair value gap
So it is a three candle sequence in order to create a fair value gap
You need you need at least three candles candles one and three's wicks do not meet which obviously you can see right in front
Of you. It is an imbalance in price. It acts as a magnet and delivers price in corresponding direction
So a sell side imbalance what this really means is the market is trying to tell you that it wants to go lower a
Sell side imbalance shows displacement towards lower prices, right? This is a very fast move where orders aren't filled
Okay, guys. So what a fair value gap is trying to tell you is that it wants to either go for lower prices or it wants
To go for higher prices. So a bearish for value gap is showing
Displacement it's the market telling you that it wants to seek lower prices
And what a bullish for value gap is trying to tell you is that it wants to seek higher prices to get this sell side
Imbalance you can expect it to target things like sell side liquidity and what a bullish for value gap is showing is bullish
Displacement in the market is telling you that price wants to seek higher prices
This could be for example buy side liquidity
So if you got super frickin confused what Blake was saying before with efficiencies and shit and nothing really made sense in your head
All you need to know is that there is an imbalance in price that needs to be corrected, right?
So as you can see here if we drag out the low of this wick
You can see that it doesn't overlap with the high of this candles way creating this imbalance
There is a gap between the low and the high meaning that is a bearish for value gap
And if we do the same thing over here the high of this first candles wick doesn't overlap with the low of this candles wick
Right here meaning that it is a for value gap
So as you can see here, this is not a for value gap
Why because the low overlaps with this candles high and as you can see there's a wick that overlaps meaning that there's no imbalance in price
And this is not what a for value gap looks like and then as you can see here
This is also not an example of a for value gap because this candle wicks high overlaps with this candle wicks low
So this is not an example of a for value gap. You need spacing between the wicks. So I decided to make you a
compilation so here on the right we have essentially from the beginning of a for value gap formation to when price actually trades into it and
Reacts right because what does price do price first creates the imbalance price trades into it and then it reacts
So as you can see here, we have the formation right you have candles one two and three here
We are talking about in a bullish sense
What happens is you have that separated wicks between candles one and three?
You can see that the high of candle one and the low of candle three both of these wicks do not meet and you can
See that right here, right? Unlike this where they're overlapping right here. They are not overlapping third
You have the actual imbalance slash for a value gap
So once you can identify that these wicks are not meeting you can mark out this actual imbalance slash for value gap price will typically
Trade into these levels which you can see illustrated here with the red candle trading into this for value gap
And then you can see the price reacts right? So if we're trading into a bullish for value gap, what are we expecting?
We're expecting a bullish reaction and for price to continue trading higher
So let's say you're looking at a bullish chart, right?
All bullish price action is gonna contain some sort of retracements when price retraces. It's typically to fill an imbalance
It's typically going to hit a fair value gap, right?
so in order for price to continue higher and needs to trade back towards these imbalances and then it will continue delivering higher and
Why price is doing this is again to fill orders
There's going to be an imbalance of orders and once price retraces into this imbalance
That is where orders get filled the same goes for in a bearish sense, right?
If you are looking at a bearish chart with bearish price action
You're gonna notice that as price is delivering lower
It is still retracing correcting these imbalances filling these orders and then it continues to deliver lower if you're looking at a bearish chart
This is what you're most likely gonna see you're gonna see price is gonna trade lower hit these for value gaps and then continue trading
Lower right price trades up hits for value gap continues or price trades up hits these bearish for value gaps continues trading lower
Right and this happens over and over and over and it will continue to push price lower
The same is going to apply in a bullish sense
If you're looking at bullish price action, you're going to notice that price will deliver higher
Retrace into these bullish fair value gaps and then continue higher, right? You'll see this all the time
Now let's show you the difference between what a fair value gap and not a fair value gap looks like in real time
Alright, so now we're gonna play through price and show you what fair value gaps actually look like on the chart
So I want you guys to know also that there doesn't actually have to be a wick as you can see here
This body does not overlap with this candles high here and this is still a fair value gap
You can imagine
They're being a wick here and as you can see these wicks do not overlap making this a bearish for value gap another bearish
Fair value gap right here and as you can see here, this is not a bearish for value gap
Why because this wick overlaps with this candles wick right here?
So this is not a bearish for value guy and trade into this bearish for value gap
And as you can see here, we then created a bullish for value gap
Why? Because Candle 1's wick does not overlap with Candle 3's wick. As you can see, this is a bullish
fair value gap, or a bissy, a buy-side imbalance. Because Candle 1's wick does not overlap with
Candle 3's wick, right? The high of Candle 1's wick does not overlap with the low of Candle 3's
wick, making this a bullish fair value gap. And as you can see here, there is no fair value gaps
getting made because all of these wicks are overlapping. And now for the most commonly
asked question. Does the size of a fair value gap matter? Well, to answer your question...
Yo, yo, yo! No, it doesn't, guys. It's all about the motion of the ocean, right? Any fair value
gap can deliver price where it needs to. So just know that. Never determine a fair value gap's
value by the size. Wow. But by its personality. Yes. And now as you can see here, we have this
bearish fair value gap. All right, little quiz time, guys. Is this a fair value gap?
Okay, the answer is no! This is not a bullish fair value gap, guys. Why? Because the wicks
overlap. So imbalance here, guys, making this not a fair value gap. If you said no,
you are correct. If you said yes, we got a little bit more studying to do. All right.
Now question number two, guys. Is this a fair value gap?
If you answered yes, you are wrong. You got a little... I'm just kidding, guys. If you answered
right, good job. I mean, really, congrats, because this is a beautiful example of a bullish fair
value gap. As you can see here, the candle one's high of this wick does not overlap with the
candle three's low of this wick. And luckily for you, if you can identify the gap with any
three candle pattern, there's a very high chance that you're not... Okay, guys. So with fair value
gaps, you'll often hear terms like respected or disrespected or a fair value gap has held
or a fair value gap has been inversed. So what does that actually mean? For a fair value gap to
get respected, the body cannot close below the fair value gap. This is in terms of a bullish
sense, of course. Yeah. So as you can see here, we trade into this bullish fair value gap. The
candle has respected this fair value gap. Why? Because the body has not closed below it. And
you guys need to be waiting for the candle to actually close on whatever timeframe you're
looking at. You'll see candles trade all the way down here, and then the candle will actually wick
and it will not close below the fair value gap. And this is still valid. This is still getting
respected. So please know, even if we have a wick that goes all the way down here, it doesn't
matter as long as the body has held. And you guys will often hear the term that wicks do the damage
and bodies tell the story, which is why you have to wait for this candle to close to see if it's
actually getting respected or not or disrespected. And what disrespected means is that the candle has
closed below this bullish fair value gap. And in a bearish fair value gap, the candle is closed
above. So just to reiterate what Blake was saying, right? Let's look at candle ones high. Candle ones
high, this wick right here. Once this candle closes below it or a candle closes below that wick's high,
then the fair value gap is considered invalidated or inversed, right? Clearly here on the right side,
you can see that price closed below this wick's high, disrespecting the fair value gap. And
remember guys, when a bullish fair value gap gets respected, what can you expect? Bullish price action
to continue, right? And if a bullish fair value gap gets disrespected, then you can expect bearish
price action to continue and for this to then sell off. And I'd say fair value gaps is considerably
one of the most important concepts to understand within the whole realm of ICT because you can
really tell where price wants to draw towards, where price wants to go next by seeing if it is
respecting or disrespecting fair value gaps, right? So if price is disrespecting bearish fair value
gaps, well, can you anticipate that price will run higher? If price is disrespecting bullish
fair value gaps, can you anticipate that it will run lower? In other words, if price is respecting
bullish fair value gaps, it'll run higher. If price is respecting bearish fair value gaps,
it'll run lower. The same applies for a bearish sense guys. Let me just do this one. The best
applies for a bearish sense guys. Irrespective and get disrespected. The same applies for a bearish
sense guys. So if you look over on the left, you can see the price three candle sequence. Three
candles? Candle one low, candle three high do not meet. Therefore you create fair value gap.
What happens? Price trades into fair value gap and it reacts. And therefore the weak respect,
the body respect, the fair value gap is respected. On the right, you have disrespected. Why? Because
the candle closes above, candle one's low and therefore the fair value gap is inverse. Right?
So price can trade all the way up here. But if it come back down and if we call the way down,
it doesn't matter. It is still respecting the fair value gap. Where did that week go? Holy shit.
All right guys, we're gonna have a fucking break dancing competition real quick, baby.
Now lock in bro. That wasn't funny. Just to give you guys a little bit more context on how to
utilize fair value gap. So as you guys know, price is fractal. And if you don't know what I'm saying
is that everything we are teaching you applies across all timeframes and it is happening all the
time, whether it is on the one minute or the one hour chart. So just to put into perspective,
if you go into the hourly timeframe, the four hour, the one hour, or if you go into the daily,
this is gonna be your higher timeframe. And inside the higher timeframe, if you see that
higher timeframe for value gaps are being respected, for example, like hourly bullish
for value gaps or like four hour bullish for value gaps or like daily, that's gonna help you with
determining your bias, right? Determining that higher timeframe drawn liquidity. But fair value
gaps within like the one and 15 minute, that's more so gonna help you with internal liquidity.
It's gonna help you determine where price is gonna wanna go to on the lower timeframe, right?
So really to simplify this, if you see prices respecting bullish or value gaps in the higher
timeframe, you can expect it to trade towards something like previous day highs or previous
week highs. Those are some buy side levels. If you see price respecting bullish or value gaps on
the one minute chart or the five minute chart, the 15 minute chart, you can expect price to trade to
those buy side liquidity levels on the lower timeframe. I'm saying this is because you don't
wanna base your entire analysis or your entry off like an hourly fair value gap and think that's
enough confluence for you to be taking a trade, right? You wanna analyze things across all
timeframes. So if you see that price is respecting bullish or value gaps on the hourly, and then you
go into the lower timeframe, and it's also respecting bullish or value gaps in the lower
timeframe. Well, you put two and two together and now you can anticipate that price wants to run
higher and figure out your targets from there. And so as we mentioned before, fair value gaps
are imbalances in price. There are times where price can create these imbalances without it being
exactly a fair value gap, right? Like you can see here, if I play out price action,
you'll notice that the candles open that just far higher than they were trading previously here.
And this typically happens when a new day of price opens up. And we call this a new day opening gap,
right? Similar to a fair value gap, this imbalance is going to attract price. Price will typically
react to it. But specifically with new day opening gaps, the one thing to note is that price will
typically fill it completely, right? Before actually making the corresponding move with
a regular bullish or value gap, you don't need to fill the fair value gap all the way for price
to continue trading higher. You can simply tap into it and buy a couple ticks, maybe fill it
halfway, maybe a third of the way, and it'll continue trading higher in a bullish sense.
But with a new day opening gap, you want to see price fill it completely before you can anticipate
that price would start trading higher. So if you play out price action, you can see that that's
exactly what happens. This occurs on Mondays. So the start of the week, you will see a new
week opening gap, most likely not all the time, but it sometimes happens on Mondays,
and a new day opening gap is just any other day of the week. So just not Monday. This happens at
6pm. That is the opening of a new day. Okay, guys, so looking at this chart right here,
I want you to identify a bullish for value gap. And then I also want you to identify
buy side liquidity. Let's see if you remember from that liquidity video that we did last.
We'll give you five seconds. Five seconds. Five, four, three, two, one, zero. Bang. There you go.
So as you can see, you have that three candle sequence in the bottom, the wick one and sorry,
the wicks of candle one and candle three do not meet, therefore creating that fair value gap,
creating that imbalance and you have that buy side level above. So what does this mean? Right? We
create a bullish for value gap and we have a buy side level above. We have some buy side liquidity.
What do we expect? We expect price to trade into this for value gap and then deliver us
towards the buy side liquidity, right? The fair value gaps are helping you understand the story
of price under helping you understand what the narrative is. So if you play price action forward,
you can see price taps into that bullish for value gap. And what happens? It goes ahead.
So now with price action played out, what do we notice? We see that price trades into this
for value gap. It does tap it a couple of times, but what does it do? It delivers us towards this
buy side liquidity up here. All right guys. And then here I want you to identify a bearish
for value gap. And then I also want you to identify some sell side liquidity here. Five seconds.
Okay. So if you answered, this is your bearish for value gap, you are correct. This is not a
bearish for value gap. Why? Because these wicks overlap. You can see that there is a lot of
displacement and a lot of candles towards this liquidity. And we have liquidity where?
Resting in this swing low here. We have more liquidity resting at this swing low and all
of these swing lows are your sell side liquidity. This is an imbalance. Price is going to trade back
up to fill these orders. And this is where a lot of sell orders are getting placed. Price trades up,
taps into this bearish for value gap, and then price delivers towards all of this sell side
liquidity. Now, if we look at price action right here, right before that sell off, what do we
notice? We notice that price has been respecting bullish for value gaps this entire time and
delivering price higher. We have this very obvious bullish for value gap right here,
which you can clearly see has been respected multiple times and price continues to deliver
higher. But what do we notice? Eventually price displaces through. We get a body closure below
this for value gap. What does that mean, guys? It's been invalidated. It's been
inversed, right? This bullish for value gap has now been disrespected and we can now anticipate
that price wants to run lower. And as you can see, price continues lower. All right, guys,
now watch this price is creating bullish for value gaps, respecting bullish for value gaps,
continuing to trade higher. This bullish for value gap gets disrespected. We create the three candle
sequence. One, two, three. We have the bullish for value gap right here. Price trades lower,
invalidates this bullish for value gap. It is now disrespected and now price goes lower after
disrespecting the bullish for value gap. And how did we identify that? We have our three candle
sequence right here. Candle one, candle two, candle three. What do we notice? Wicks of candle
one are not intersecting with the wick of candle three or four. We create this imbalances for value
gap, this buy side imbalance. And now if I play the next candle, you can see that this
candle displaces lower, closes below candle one's wick. In other words, the body closes below this
for value gap, disrespecting the fair value gap and inversing it. When this happens, you can
anticipate that price will continue lower. So as you can see, this candle closes below that bullish
for value gap. After this bullish for value gap gets inverse, we trade into this one right after
we inverse the next bullish for value gap, we can see that we get a body closure below that bullish
for value gap. Therefore it is disrespected. We wait again. We can also see that this candle
disrespects this bullish for value gap through a body closure below. Therefore it is also inversed.
All three of these bullish for value gaps have been disrespected. And now we can anticipate that
price will continue running lower. And as you can see, it runs all the way down here. What do we
notice here? We see that after delivering lower price opens up a bearish for value gap. We have
that three candle sequence. You have candles one, two, and three. What do we notice? We notice that
candle one's wick does not overlap with candle three's wick. Therefore we create a fair value
gap immediately after price displaces higher disrespects this bearish for value gap. Also
meaning it got inversed. We also start trading into this bearish for value gap and then eventually
price inverses this one as well. Both of these for value gaps get disrespected. And what happens
now? Price continues running higher. So hopefully that helped you understand a little bit more about
how price reacts to fair value gaps, what it means for it to get respected, what it means for it to
get disrespected, and what does that mean for the overall narrative of price and where it wants to
go. All right guys, and please remember that the timeframe you are on matters. Because again, fair
value gap is going to occur on every single timeframe. Like the five minute, the 15 minute,
the daily, right? And you want to be utilizing that same candle for whatever timeframe for value gap
you're looking at to determine whether it is getting respected or disrespected. You can see here,
we have this bullish for value gap, right? And you want to be looking at this on the five minute
timeframe. Why? Well, if you look at this five minute for value gap on the say one minute
timeframe, see that the candle has actually closed below on this one minute timeframe. But that does
not mean that this fair value gap is disrespected because the candle still hasn't closed on this
five minute timeframe. You can see the fair value gap is actually getting respected on the five
minute timeframe and we continue bullish price action. So guys, don't just go on different
timeframes to look at whether a fair value gap is getting respected or disrespected. Stay on the
timeframe that the fair value gap has occurred in. Okay, and as you guys can see here, we have a
bearish for value gap. And as you can see here on this five minute timeframe, this bearish for value
gap is getting respected. And what you don't want to do is go on the lower timeframe, for example,
the one minute and look at that fair value gap. Because what you can see here is we actually close
above this for value gap on the one minute timeframe, actually close above this for value
gap on the one minute timeframe. But remember, this is not valid because the five minute candle
has still not closed. And once this five minute candle has closed, we respect it and then price
trades lower. All right, guys, that concludes our ICT for dummies episode five, where we teach you
how to make money. Fair value gaps. All right, guys, well, we hope you enjoyed that lesson.
We are going to be giving you some homework for you to spend 29 hours in a row without eating
and finding 150 fair value gaps. No, I'm kidding. But you should definitely spend some time on the
charts today or whenever you can and try to identify at least 10 fair value gaps, see whether it is
being respected or disrespected. Remember, the bodies are what matters here. Wicks do the damage,
bodies tell the story. Once again, we hope you enjoyed this video. We look forward to seeing you
in our next lesson. And we promise you that if you watch this entire series and you understand
everything, by the end of it, you will be ready to make your first million goddamn dollars. All
right. We are still starting off a little bit simple. Everything will get more intricate as we
go. We'll teach you how to build the model. We'll even show you our model. But for now,
we got to start off with the basics. That being said, we'll see you later, boys. Thanks for
watching. Make sure to like, subscribe and comment below. Holy shit. I've always wanted to say that.